everything has a process like with math
you learn the formulas and [ __ ] and then
you start to get results because you can
do every [ __ ] problem if you know the
formula you go homes in you got a
formula yeah yeah I got it talk to him
my formula you give up the whole sauce
for real bro without the chef's though
that's what I'm saying you don't let
nobody interrupts your sauce when you
cooking people have lost the
understanding and value of the word you
because at the end of the night you
gotta lay down by yourself and get up in
the morning look yourself in the mirror
you got to be comfortable with all the
decisions that you make as a human and
stop depending on other people to supply
your happiness won't sneeze thoughts and
desires mmm it's selfish but it's real
and when you start believing in other
people but that's how you open yourself
up to disappointments failures
heartbreak depression all that [ __ ] cuz
your expectations it's the fastest way
to disappointment I'll never let nobody
or nothing disappoint you gotta be
comfortable with yourself and know that
you are the key factor that could change
the old situation your life at the end
of the day you are the [ __ ] you are
the key the other DJ Kelly's a major key
yeah yeah but you are the key and every
time you can put some knowledge and work
it and execute it it's just like you got
another one on your on your looper keys
the more cheese you got the less you
need from other [ __ ] if you're
looking for somebody to make you
financially happy and that's all you
need you want somebody cuz they got
money or whatever you think they can do
for you think of how you gonna feel when
you in that position and and you're not
looking for nobody else to give you what
you've been craving if money is your
vice and you get some money then what
you're gonna have to find another vice
because money ain't gonna be your it's
not gonna be a drug no more cuz you're
in excess of it and it's the thrill is
gone like though blues song baby became
the thrill of it's gone
it's the thrill of the chase there's a
lot of [ __ ] that we think that we want
until we actually get it so is that
where you are right now like you've
gotten a lot of what you want and it's
not what you thought it would be no it's
not even that it's just that's why I can
say that I'm happy with where I am in my
successes
personal however people may see it or
not I do what makes me happy you know
what I'm saying sometimes it's not a
Ferrari that [ __ ] that's your dream
car your [ __ ] might be right there in
your grass it might be the [ __ ]
Mustang that you wanted in high school
you know I'm saying you always just
wanted the GT or some crazy [ __ ]
whatever it is that you desire see
that's what separates the people from
leg-like greatness and regular
[ __ ] desire the desire to be
yourself you know I'm saying like you
look I'm sitting here watching these
[ __ ] build his car you might
look at that [ __ ] be like I don't want
that [ __ ] but that's somebody's dream
car that's all they ever wanted you know
I'm saying yeah and so that's the type
of [ __ ] I'm saying is like what is it
that makes you happy
it might not even be your iPhone it
might just you guys got to live for
yourself is basically what I'm saying
your happiness stars in ears with you
you being on the other side it's like
and just this being the follow-up
interview before you were on the rise
and you're still rising this is by no
means like you're still almost you just
getting started and where you're
actually gonna end up but as you've
seems like you've seen the other side of
the fence now and you've maybe been in
certain rooms with certain people and
you've seen the quote important people
right what it what does that reveal to
you it's just what I'm finished saying
all that is what you learned in that's
what I am break your head it's like you
sit you can be around
give me just your idols man and that's
it then you just see like damn that's
what make you connect with them the
realness
you have the same somebody you're like
when somebody meets somebody said damn
you're so down there it's just a
relatable cool dude it's because it
wasn't trying to pretend to be the
[ __ ] you thought that they were
yeah you know what I'm saying those are
the people who are really the happiest
man and that's what I'm seeing a lot of
people missing out in their world you
know I'm saying a lot of people just
depressed or just chasing [ __ ] that they
think that they're supposed to have to
make people like them and it's sad but
that's how you see a lot of people get
lost in the entertainment field they
start chasing things items objects and
people
you gotta have a vision now mmm so like
how did you develop your vision because
you've made I'll in there I actually
went through and did it you know what
I'm saying I know none of the [ __ ] that
I have or got in my comedy career
entertainment career was handed to me I
actually had to physically put labour
into it mm-hmm
so that's what made me start saying like
okay [ __ ] if I do this and this happens
or this doesn't happen then what you
know I mean cuz you still gotta stay
busy in between these projects that [ __ ]
don't come out when you do it you gotta
stay behind until this [ __ ] come on you
don't want to have the hottest TV show
on on TV and you fell off in the six
months it took for them to anything yeah
you got job and [ __ ] you a waiter you
gotta quit your job so you can go to
your premiere yeah yeah yeah I mean we
we shot a TV show together a little
while ago it was just like a little
pilot yeah and it was dope too
that was my first time being around
comedians of that caliber where I'm like
oh these are like Broadway part of some
classic [ __ ] now bro we working with
Donnell Rawlings
Charlie Marley Murphy did and it was and
then it was like the Mike Epps project
that yeah that's what it was that's what
it was and when man it's just crazy how
that happen I never forgot about that
and even even the writers were dope
these were dudes who had written on like
South Park and in living color like the
whole project I was like yeah and then
it's one of those things that you know
just never kind of well of course not
without Charlie of course right all
right I mean general it never really
being there and being a part of it I
know that that [ __ ] was funny is he so
funny
and it was it's probably still could
come out hopefully one day somebody
wants to see it you have a lot of
projects that you shoot and then they
just just that's just the game yeah I
think that's just part of the game
I mean it's people out there and we've
got a hundred pilots so 20 or 30
probably a great shows that they stopped
production made episode I'm not [ __ ]
away right just just because of the
politics at a game it's not always about
the the quality of the show the people
who run it
he's business people up top
sit back and they wanna they flip
channels and they want to be part of the
wave of what's hot and new right now
they just and they lose focus because
they have a boss who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about that they just saw that this show
is doing that and that's what the
network is doing yep exactly
it's [ __ ] a lot like a lot of talent
get lost in that because you know people
don't worry likes rejection or feeling
like they fail whether it be your father
at night so you [ __ ] around and lose a
job or some [ __ ] you thought that you
was gonna you know some income that she
was expecting and you don't know how to
bounce back that shaking cause
depression and drugs and all types of
[ __ ] burr you've been down that road
yeah yeah I lost a lot of money doing
this [ __ ] talk about it bro tell him I
lost about twenty five thousand dollars
for some cruises for some tweets you
just had some tweets they didn't approve
of yeah
what were they oh [ __ ] tweet write some
[ __ ] like that I don't give a [ __ ] man I
don't nobody run my [ __ ] and a lot of
these promoters and people who booked
you for shows they think that that gives
them access to your social media with
you the promoter I gotta be the promoter
and the talent [ __ ] you I'm not doing
that [ __ ] unless that's part of the pay
I'm gonna post the [ __ ] to let the
people know then follow me to come [ __ ]
with me but I'm not about to promote
this [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] you talking about you the headliner
were you to promote it your name says
promoter
they're not coming they're coming
because you told them I was coming it's
not to see a lot of times you go do
shows in these cities and then why the
[ __ ] didn't sell out it's not that they
don't [ __ ] with me they don't [ __ ] with
you I'm coming to do a show in your city
where you live you don't in your
promoter and you don't know 300 people
how you promoted in you can't bring 200
people to a club 300 people you the
promoter half of the club posed to beat
your people promoter the other
you possibly Shahar we can about how to
add another show cuz cuz I promoted this
[ __ ] well man you ain't did [ __ ] is that
the game is ugly man